vsauce kevin here and you just lost
a dollar i mean not literally this is
just a fictional scenario that examines
an unexpected slice
of numerical cognition and in our
scenario
a dollar is mysteriously missing
you and your friends michael and jake
went out to lunch and split the 30
dollar bill
evenly you paid 10 bucks each
but the server accidentally overcharged
you and the bill
should have been only twenty five
dollars so she gives the bus boy your
five dollar
refund but he can't figure out how to
evenly divide it
amongst three people and frankly you
don't even know that you've been
overcharged so he just takes a two
dollar tip for his efforts and gives
you michael and jake one dollar back
each so now you've only paid nine
dollars each for lunch
nine plus nine plus nine equals twenty
seven
plus the bus boy kept two dollars for
himself
for a total of twenty nine dollars
but you originally paid thirty dollars
so a dollar is missing
how does a dollar disappear where is the
missing dollar
before we break down this riddle let's
try this with
different numbers and just see what
happens let's say you still pay a 30
bill but this time the server realizes
there's been a
huge mistake and the total should have
been only
10 bucks so now the busboy gets 20
dollars to return to you
michael and jake which he also cannot
divide
equally you don't know about the exact
price change so the busboy takes his two
dollar tip
leaving him with 18 to cleanly divide
three ways
he refunds each of you six bucks
reducing your effective price to
four dollars each so you paid four plus
four plus four which is twelve plus the
busboy tip of two dollars
equals fourteen dollars and just like
that
sixteen dollars is gone because you only
paid
fourteen dollars for a thirty dollar
bill
no no no
something is clearly wrong with this
setup
this is actually a pretty popular and
rather old riddle it seems to have
originated in the mid
1700s with mathematician francis walking
games tudors
assistant a sort of arithmetic textbook
if 48 taken from 120 leaves 72 and 72
taken from 91 leaves 19 and 7 taken from
thence leaves 12
what number is that out of which when
you have taken 48 72
19 and 7 leaves 12.
part of what makes the missing dollar
riddle confusing is that it bombards you
with numbers that's okay though because
your abilities with numerical cognition
are actually
pretty good yale cognitive scientist
karen nguyen found that
infants can understand simple arithmetic
like one plus one equals two
if i bombard you with numbers like two
plus five plus three plus one plus seven
plus twelve
you aren't confused about what's
happening and you can work
through it to an answer of
but when context is added to those
numbers it's easy to get
sidetracked we get so wrapped up in
what's happening with the lunch
the refund and the busboy that we gloss
over the real math
and here 9 plus 9 plus 9 plus 2
equals 29 and wonder where the dollar
went
but it's not missing we just played a
mathematical
sleight of hand here's the breakdown we
started with 30
25 of that is still in the restaurant's
cash register
the other five have been given back
three dollars have been returned to you
and two dollars for the bus boys tip 25
plus 3 plus 2 equals 30.
so where's the disconnect really
where exactly is the disconnect
let's find it there are really two huge
problems in this riddle one is how we
think about that
three refunded dollars we're only
considering it once
when we really need to consider it twice
and the second problem is how we're
incorrectly
factoring in the busboys tip let's talk
about that tip
first because the busboy takes his two
dollar tip
that's money that's never returned to
you
michael or jake and therefore must now
be considered as part of the total cost
of the lunch which means that the new
cost of the meal is the 25
still in the cash register plus the bus
boys two dollar tip
equaling 27 when each of the three of
you pays 10 bucks and then gets one
dollar back your effective cost of the
meal
the food plus the waiter's tip is nine
dollars each for
27 total that leaves
three dollars missing the three dollars
returned to you
by the busboy so now we're left with the
three dollar problem
the nine plus nine plus nine plus two
equation of the riddle
is simply the wrong equation actually as
we just learned the nines are right
but the two is wrong the two is already
factored into the nines what we need to
do is add
back the three which is kind of
confusing and
part of that sleight of hand the riddle
uses the three to subtract from the
customer's new
final total cost of the meal but we have
to
add it back in at the end to get to the
original 30 dollars that changed hands
look you paid ten dollars each refund
your three dollars taking the amount
paid down to 27 and then
give the busboy his two dollar tip and
the restaurant keeps 25
there is no missing dollar
the riddle is just answering the right
question
the wrong way legendary statistician
john tuckey once said
an approximate answer to the right
question is worth a great deal more
than a precise answer to the wrong
question
when it comes to the missing dollar
riddle
the precise answer to the right question
is worth at least
a buck and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you